we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here's an
interesting voicemail that came in over
the weekend yeah david it's kind of
hypocritical you're taking things ever
naathan all a day that celebrates the
exploitation and Native Americans by the
white man you know this is just a recent
confirmation that you're just part of
the white power structure yeah it's
funny because when we took off Columbus
Day people said David how dare you take
off columbus day given what it
represents and uh now we've taken off
another federal holiday and I guess
we're going to get critiqued when we
take Christmas off because I don't know
because I'm Jewish or it's a
representation of the lack of separation
of church and state a federally
sanctioned religious holiday we take
days off and it seems more logical to me
to take days off where people are sort
of away and paying less attention to
shows and podcasts it means nothing in
particular about our views on any of
these holidays but I guess you just
can't avoid criticism no matter what you
do and what's funny is that when we
decide to take off a random day if I I'm
extending a long weekend by a day or
getting out of town early by a day
people say hey there was no reason to
take this particular day off it wasn't a
holiday or anything like that so you
can't win as we know is the case with
with those who want to troll on the
bonus show today this is amazing African
elephants are being born without tusks
due to poaching what is this going to do
to the poaching industry also Nestle and
coca-cola are attempting to block
national parks from banning bottled
water sales I have a lot of thoughts
about that and I also want to talk about
an upcoming Freedom of Information Act
segment that we're going to do and get
some advice from the audience about the
best way to go about it we actually did
it before and I'm going to do it again
and I want to sort of tweak what we do
in requesting my record so to speak
remember you can get a free 2017 day
Pakman show calendar with a yearly
membership by going to david pakman.com
slash calendar 17 if you just want the
calendar you can also get that at david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 and if
you're not interested in the calendar
but you do want to get access to the
members only bonus show which we do
every day just for our paid subscribers
but the normal prices of six dollars a
month and 60 bucks a year are a bit
steep I want people involved at whatever
level is affordable so we have a really
really good discount code that code
write this down is I voted 17 all
lowercase all one word I voted 17 you
can use that code for a major discount
off of membership at david pakman.com
slash membership and i look forward to
speaking to all of our existing and
soon-to-be new members on the bonus show
including today it's going to be a good
one